he knows I'm a little yeah I don't know
if he understood me but I definitely
like grow up Oh fan I think he knows all
right we're gonna get our next matchup a
Kay's gonna be staying up on the stage
but first he's gonna be going up against
booked the whole town hero
this is serious time in the serious boy
time all right guys I got a hard
question for you guys out there uh-huh
would you guys like a ke to take it make
some noise if you guys would like book
to win make some noise out there gonna
be crazy cuz cuz we saw how book was
able to deal with the Coomer earlier on
right so that might be putting some kind
of thoughts here into his head this is
the longer set - yes yes as long as it
so this is a race to three so maybe you
could try Shaheen out for the pitch you
know or maybe if you try a cool yeah
either way that's the thing yes multiple
characters but that's not to say book
doesn't have multiple characters either
we have not seen him yet use another
character in the LCQ yes but there's a
good chance he has uh he is known to
have a few good characters against Akuma
I've seen him play like you mentioned
before he we've seen him like ISA no
other characters like he goes to Shaheen
Yeah right away to the Habibi right the
shitty book has put so much fear into
the cool players it seems like yeah
another one right now anyways we're
gonna start this off this is our losers
finals one of these two players will
move on against the bill all from
Pakistan in our grand finals but only
one yeah so like the other person's
going on yeah and and for something for
one of these players home is just down
street yeah we'll see Shaheen buses Jen
there we go
do that woody bleeped I sound like you
say it taking seven for say let's get
into it dancing a little bit Oh
side step on the for for gifts the down
for two huh no break his legs down chop
into that low is so good and it's a
transition yeah first route to ake a
look at what open it by having another
like really good character the [ __ ]
is so good I mean this is just a pattern
of poking right now when you saw it
okay with three down four ones and does
another one inside steps it's just it's
gonna be a really really interesting but
matching oh here look at this is big
he's gonna close it out yeah I'm that
new move from the starts as well
guaranteed here on the floor fight it's
a generous my god yeah whatever you're
gonna do you want to make make sure it's
as disrespectful as possible that's the
name of the game right yep he's gonna
put back to the wall that was so sick
doing it look with rage now rage
unavailable carried over from the last
few matches we've seen him on say he is
feeling himself he's got super
passionate player we were talking about
this earlier today
when he lost a trip major was his infant
like you saw it in his face in tears the
whole nine do puts a lot into his
gameplay yeah
both these guys do man both these guys
who says a lot on the line man but yeah
okay that was very convincing but it
looks like he's blocked the stage like
he's sticking with Jin hair I don't know
if I agree with this but you could
definitely make the adaptation book
stripping very strong today
yeah then that last match very much look
one-sided he's got a K was ducking
strings he was interrupted really well
sidestepping perfectly super on point
man yeah I remember a case started this
top 32 in loser spot a long road but you
can't take that away from my local
people y'all wanna come lose a side you
can't say anything today unless they
picked Akuma to the Mishima dojo
starting it off sticking to their guns
whole bed really yeah cuz he's using to
what now because the second hit standing
when he's trying to be down for two off
of the sidestep so good adaptation
different book down three in the slide
good quick sidewalks
good punished by finally getting the
ball he had a chance not gonna be 133 3
no ok with the adjustment and he takes
and steals that round it's not gonna let
me get around alright drink he's making
a Sharpie like that bro I'm trying to
give back I'm trying to get the Grand
Finals man yeah what do you call it a
night nil what do you call that is that
that's beyond around that's beyond
around Brown enter the Shadow Realm
going all the way down bro
yes point ducking was scared of the
house sweet heavy code book should be
under finish this wall LS there are no
on every dog I should have said yes
that's a bad way to die yeah definitely
got scared where the jungle baby's gonna
just got a weird and always make her out
there a you know they make those up this
really
[Music]
account for it - there's a lot of
screaming in the crowd Oh
counter-hit - definitely man a kid's
looking really really strong here so far
the matchup you know book he's been
struggling almost the entire time hear
that David he tried harder like the
baguette Jesus yeah you suck the hub
kick man range available for book now
dice good space it back it's a pick up
the drive race right oh it wasn't gonna
be some i gosh this guy the disrespect I
felt it I felt it by the way that was
crazy I definitely felt that clock reset
aka is a type of player he plays purely
face on feel yeah and you saw it there
man he knew he just had a pin anyway
look this slide yeah this could be
doesn't look like he wants to switch
characters just thinking about yeah I
think you're just going to count the
select screen just to take a bit of time
to think he now needs
now whatever parity fix now is locked in
with and it looks like he's gone for gin
hair down to zero you have to stick with
your best character this is a character
that's got you this far even if a K has
more characters right we even know he
hasn't Akuma but we've seen him play
other characters outside of that so will
he change probably not but the fact is
he has them there if he feels like it's
out of control
he has potential answers across the
board but here we go yeah does it look
pretty one-sided so far but can book
bring it back this is Last Chance Saloon
here man
he's locked in with gin - oh down versus
aka if he's gonna do it he's got to do
it now and he can't lose any more
matches here we go break his legs I like
that noise nice good combo but doesn't
get the - it for the water book good so
far
slide counted hit yeah a case a case to
comfortable right now oh my god
yeah he was ready with that launch there
on the width pop kick the table in it
missed again
book is about making a ke pay for any of
these big reading so no he's not
doubting himself
at all a K is so comfortable right now
he's doing what you want take his rhythm
is just like he's imposing his will on
him pretty much he is making him play
his match yes okay here we go blocks the
sliding it's the punish this time with
the wall on top of account good break on
the throat watch out for that whipped
rage drive you gotta watch out for it
has been dangerous and I feel like never
sleep we haven't seen so many house team
strongly from good man in fact we hardly
use that yeah I mean you think about it
mean a KS reacting to faster moves so
everybody must be deathly probably gonna
block that
deep in the psyche again so make it work
I feel like at this point they're just
spacing wise it's not giving them an
opportunity to even get close enough to
get in there for it to move great timing
once again fish if you wants to get
those big heads yeah just like that
okay we'll move on to set points that
move into the grand finals here can you
do it all bring it back to come in I can
feel it doc you had a count here that
lost chance for a necessary risk yeah
now that's what you need to do to make a
play that was a big chunk of damage
together and no punishment on the town
for two moving Grand Finals ladies and
gentlemen
however please please make some noise
for book ladies and gentleme is out of
the LCQ that's gonna be the rough boys
twt season but what a showing man that's
the hometown here all right there yeah
one of my personal favorite players to
talk to Oh
watch and just a good friend of mine
sorry hotshot guy very strong player you
know represents this country very well
most the time when he's abroad he know
where he's the only guy representing
Thailand it's a big big pressure man